[Música]
guillermo lasso continuará al frente del
gobierno ecuatoriano
el mandatario superó el pedido de
destitución en la asamblea nacional que
habían presentado diputados afines al ex
presidente rafael correa esto al tiempo
que el gobierno congeló las
negociaciones con los indígenas que
llevan 16 días de protestas
jornada histórica para colombia la
comisión de la verdad entidad que nació
de los acuerdos de paz con la extinta
guerrilla de las farc presentó su
informe final tras más de tres años de
investigaciones el presidente de electo
gustavo petro aseguró que con la verdad
el país no busca venganza sino a avanzar
en la paz
las autoridades de texas elevaron a 51
el número de migrantes que fueron
hallados muertos dentro de un camión a
causa de las altas temperaturas en la
localidad de san antonio hay tres
detenidos que presuntamente harían parte
de una red de tráfico de personas
bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
ecuador donde la asamblea nacional no
aprobó el pedido de destitución del
presidente guillermo lasso que había
sido presentado por asambleístas
opositores por conmoción interna los
votos a favor de la destitución no
fueron suficientes para que el
mandatario tenga que dejar el cargo esto
cuando se cumplen 16 días de protesta en
el país y en medio de máxima tensión
luego de que el gobierno levantará las
conversaciones con el líder de los
indígenas luego de que un militar
muriera en medio de enfrentamientos con
manifestantes
producto de este repudiable hecho
falleció el sargento de nuestras fuerzas
armadas
jose simarro además cayeron heridos 12
miembros de la policía nacional y de las
fuerzas armadas
varios de ellos de gravedad- el país ha
sido testigo de todos los esfuerzos que
hemos hecho para entablar un diálogo
fructífero y sincero
además hemos dado respuestas concretas a
las demandas de nuestros hermanos
indígenas pero no volveremos a sentarnos
a dialogar con leonidas iza quien solo
defiende sus intereses políticos y no
los de sus bases vamos a colombia
después de tres años de trabajo en la
comisión de la verdad dio a conocer el
informe de su investigación que recoge
más de 30.000 testimonios de víctimas
del conflicto armado que ha tenido el
lugar en ese país por cinco décadas
ahora queda por delante dos meses de
socialización
hay futuro si hay verdad es la primera
frase de los hallazgos y recomendaciones
del informe de la comisión de la verdad
en colombia así habló su presidente
francisco de roux y nos tomaría 17 años
darle un minuto para honrar a cada una
de las víctimas
sin la presencia del presidente iván
duque pero con el presidente electo
gustavo petro este prometió leer las
recomendaciones que salen de los
hallazgos las generaciones de 200 años
de soledad' si tienen
oportunidad una segunda oportunidad
junto a the roof nueve comisionados el
español carlos beristáin ya ha
participado en otras comisiones antes
rescate el buen nombre de millones de
personas y es una buena noticia también
para otros países además de víctimas del
conflicto también estuvieron antiguos
victimarios como rodrigo londoño ex
comandante de las farc en la medida en
que se recuerdan las recomendaciones en
la makers intur aris el el horror que
ver el conflicto para que no se vuelva a
repetir la comisión de la verdad surgió
de los acuerdos de paz entre el estado y
las farc de 2016 forma parte del sistema
integral para la paz
juliette de rivero representante de la
alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos en colombia habló para
france24 donde esperamos que sean las
víctimas realmente las que escriban la
historia de colombia y que por fin
podamos rechazar la violencia entre los
hallazgos se encontró que el 80 por
ciento de las víctimas del conflicto han
sido civiles la comisión habló durante
más de tres años con más de 30 mil
víctimas pese a todo para el escritor y
profesor fernando ayala hay esperanza no
es de funeral para colombia si no es un
día de renacimiento real de haberlo
hecho si hubiera un relato histórico que
trata de entender lo que pasó para que
el conflicto por fin termine
al lado y lado de la frontera se han
sentido las reacciones por la muerte de
decenas de emigrantes al interior de un
camión en texas en eeuu el presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
quien se reunirá con su homólogo
estadounidense joe biden el próximo 12
de julio ofreció sus condolencias y
ayuda con el traslado de los cuerpos a
su vez el gobierno de guatemala confirmó
que siete de las víctimas eran
guatemaltecas el informe es de natalia
plazas
[Música]
conmoción a lado y lado de la frontera
tras uno de los episodios más letales de
la trata de personas de la historia
reciente la muerte de 51 migrantes en un
camión en texas causó indignación en la
ciudad de tapachula en méxico donde
muchas otras personas aguardan
intentando llegar también a eeuu han
militarizado toda la frontera sur y los
camiones siguen pasando llenos de
inmigrantes invisibles
que
cerraron esos camiones que llevan
migrantes asignados pasan invisibles por
chiapas y hasta ya que llegan a morir
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador expresó también sus
condolencias a las familias y prometió
apoyo en el traslado de los cuerpos así
como esclarecer lo ocurrido en
territorio mexicano nos corresponde
porque estos hechos
lamentables que desde luego tienen que
ver
con
la situación
de pobreza
[Aplausos]
desesperación
de hermanos centroamericanos
de mexicanos entre tanto robert biggs
quien apoyó a los rescatistas en texas
aún no da crédito a lo ocurrido no
no he visto nada así en los años que
llevo haciendo
es una de esas cosas que es realmente
devastadora
las autoridades locales respondieron a
un llamado de emergencia que reportaba
gritos dentro del camión al llegar ya
había en el vehículo decenas de muertos
16 personas entre las cuales cuatro
niños fueron llevadas a hospitales en
situación de insolación
en chile la comisión constitucional
finalizó la redacción y votación del
borrador de la nueva carta magna del
país tras un año de trabajo el texto
será entregado el lunes al presidente
gabriel boric y está previsto que sea
sometido a plebiscito el próximo 4 de
septiembre si el documento es aprobado
por la ciudadanía reemplazará a la
constitución heredada de la dictadura de
augusto pinochet el texto contempla un
estado garante en salud educación
vivienda digna y pensión
a 20 años de prisión fue condenada a
ghislain maxwell la ex amante y
colaboradora del financiero jeffrey
epstein tras haber sido declarada
culpable de cinco cargos relacionados
con el tráfico sexual de menores de edad
que maxwell reclutaba para epp singh
ante el tribunal la condenada reconoció
el dolor de todas sus víctimas pero no
pidió perdón
finalmente 20 años de prisión
creo que 20 años es razonable estamos
felices de tener finalmente un cierre y
comenzar un nuevo capítulo en nuestras
vidas
la británica william maxwell de 60 años
mano derecha y pareja del fallecido
financiero jeffrey epstein fue condenada
este martes luego de ser declarada
culpable de cinco cargos relacionados
con tráfico sexual de menores entre los
años 1994 y 2004 las víctimas acogieron
la sentencia de la corte federal de
manhattan con satisfacción pero con
dolor su victimaria no pidió perdón por
sus actos durante la lectura de la
sentencia
su declaración no aparecía una disculpa
muy vacía no asumió la responsabilidad
de los delitos que cometió y se sintió
como una vez más que intentaba hacer
algo para beneficiarse y en absoluto
sobre el daño que había causado
ojalá se repitiera cuando estaba ocupada
obligándome a entrar en una habitación
para que me violaran debía haberse
arrepentido entonces de hecho ni
siquiera debería haber una disculpa
violaciones violaciones según los
relatos de las víctimas
maxwell era la encargada de ganarse su
confianza para seducirlas y llevarlas
ante epstein quien abusaba sexualmente
de ellas la hija del difunto varón de la
prensa británica jeffrey maxwell pasará
posiblemente el rey su vida entre rejas
sin embargo su abogada señaló que
apelará la condena al considerarla
injusta en world skies
gillane apelar a este caso y confiamos
en que prevalecerá en la apelación todos
sabemos que la persona que debería haber
sido sentenciada hoy escapó de la
responsabilidad
la jueza sentenció que maxwell estaba
siendo castigada por sus crímenes
atroces y depredadores el final en
desgracia para la socialité anglosajona
y una luz de justicia para las víctimas
fin del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]